hooked up hooked up no you should just
just stay up there yeah I got to get the
top shelf
love it here roar yeah Oh what is that
guy kettles didn't see what the hell is
that guy oh my god it's the ogre and
ogre use your rockets or whatever you
guys have actually hurts pretty bad oh I
think I got my special to God up down
that was easy Shh fri more of them yeah
bring it on man let him come how does a
shot three rockets at them that it
didn't drop anything though and
uneventful was it punch do it through
this doorway guys is that night too
there's an idea troll just running at
you and die great
oh I didn't mean to do that not mean to
do that
how's that night his head do it I'm feet
and walk beam up yeah let's beat him up
what are you guys doing boomer have you
shot gunned them into the wall I should
have supercharged them but I don't know
I feel like when you supercharged just a
night it's like a waste Oh what are they
bowing down to what are you getting
worship being quiet to fight that big
old ball all right everybody sneaking
mode again oh oh whoa disengage it's
like oh crap oh we already blew the
stealth options they probably had like
one of the rear I'm way alarm yeah where
are we going I feel like there ought to
be like a hidden chest somewhere around
I shoot the core no guys I'm acolytes on
the left side
yeah that's right although the Ruby all
right where are you gonna look oh he
wants inside I got it on the boy we're
gonna board defendant here probably sure
thing about any load a shotgun oh that
longer no my bad guys alright i'm
getting a shotgun and bush I've been
learned it's powerful its Terry true I
think you know how use that right it's
like you have to charge it and then let
go and screwed yeah that kind of sucks
that doesn't stop I just don't look I'm
not a big fan of it yes I really don't
like it Oh a good an Engram ruin a are
now that's good all right they're coming
from this way kill the night yo the
night where is the night though give me
the details under tunnel right oh we got
for all you got night oh look at that
guy's freaking huge immune to whatever
to onyx guy my god oh he's a skull to
what bread house burger let's go yeah
everybody really spread out try and get
revives if you uh hang on goes down for
coming damage cuz I feel like there's
only one of us allow for dads wish she
sold
oh good all the rocket missed of course
it missed oh jeez you guys both have
snipers right yeah I should switch to a
sniper but then I won't have bullets oh
he's almost said he's all said he's
almost said where's this just phase one
whoo he wants me oh what's blood no this
is not even my final they did that's
great all right I don't know Chris but
uh someone take my mic down take my
buddy
oh god it's not inverted challenge mode
no I met a bullet Chris let me bring up
his feet there's a giant man trying to
murder us he's about 60 feet tall yeah
that sounds fine yeah it's pretty good
I'm down with that yeah I'm not down
with this please not is low on oh yeah
of course I met evolved normally both no
space don't worry guys I've got some
ammo oh we get in we go to we got a
night over here too you mean like not a
giant one yes correct
the guy ones left without its then I was
so satisfying to head shot that big dude
is diggin you guys hang on the weirdest
places Troy it was I not supposed to do
that Oh Ryan you screwed it all oh no I
broke it oh you broke the game though
that was actually the destiny server
your shot I'll rude Oh rude oh let's go
chest on it was oh that's good timing
since I was completely out of ammo King
well not anymore whatever it is it's
still out there